like a sort of a ghastly case from the
Mets history and I want to talk about
that briefly and what we're doing to fix
the issues that it highlights obviously
you're all aware that from sort of day
one high standards has been top of my
Jennifer my commissionship I've been
very honest about the fact that
um I'm sort of pleased to have tens of
thousands of great men and women and I'm
always mindful that they listen to my
words as do the people of London who we
who we serve
and we're all equally horrified that we
have hundreds in policing who shouldn't
be here and David Carrick is an example
of a awful example of that
I must reiterate here my sincere
apologies to his victims for our
failings he should not have been a
police officer
um that's very obvious
um a range of poor policy and poor
decision-making he shouldn't have been a
police officer and we failed
and we haven't we haven't applied the
same sense of ruthlessness to guarding
our own integrity
that we routinely apply to confronting
criminals and I'm deeply sorry for that
I think we failed as investigators where
we should have been more intrusive and
join the dots over his repeated misogyny
over decades
and as Leaders our mindset should have
been more determined to spot and root
out such a misogynist
so as I say I apologize to his victims
and I want to say sorry to all the women
across London who feel let down by this
and whose trust in policing is shaken by
this
I want to talk about three things that
we're doing on top of action about
review
um and about acceleration so about
action I promised action from day one
um four months ago I set out to be
ruthless at rooting out those corrupt
our integrity
we've increased the resources in our
department Professional Standards
significantly we've established an
anti-corruption and abuse command
and we've launched the first ever uh
public appeal line through Crime
Stoppers The Crime Stoppers police
Integrity hotline
and we're getting sort of tens of calls
a week to that that are leading us to
look at new cases some of those turned
out to be malicious but some of them
turned out to be substantive and those
are generating new caseload and I think
in some ways the sort of tragedy of the
situation we find ourselves in we are
leading the way it's interesting that
even though this is a met appeal one in
three of the calls coming through
roughly after the forces that we're
passing information on as well so
um I think we're sort of through our uh
our challenges we're helping the rest of
policing confront some issues as well
that's some of the action we're taking
so far
um I want to talk about review and
redress
um clearly in terms of this particular
case the Home Secretary I think is
rightly suggested that
um lady Ailey shangelini widens the
scope of her review
um to include this case and we'll
support that fully in terms of things
that we're doing
um I want to talk about operation Onyx
and about uh
um use of data to review the vetting of
all officers and staff
so in terms of operation Onyx or project
onyx
what is very clear isn't it is that we
have if we haven't been tough enough in
our decision making previously
you have to look back at previous cases
and say
are there other cases that we got wrong
where we decided somebody was going to
stay in the organization
and in hindsight that's wrong
so we've cast The Net very wide
if you look at so we looked at last
decade officers and staff who have had
analogation which has any hint of a sort
of
sexual misconduct or or domestic abuse
so these range from
um less serious allegations that are
sort of largely sort of verbal for
example all the way through to Serious
sexual assault allegations
every one of them has been previously
investigated and dealt with as either
criminality or misconduct and
um come to a position where those people
remain in the organization
what we have to work out is did we get
those decisions right some of the
reporting in the papers is this is a
thousand new cases not a thousand new
cases it's reviewing all cases and given
what but given what we have found so far
with um the cases that come to like
Carrick
we have to assume that whilst I'd be
confident that many of the cases we got
right
we have to accept that we'll probably
find many cases we got wrong and there
were people there that we need to have a
fresh look at that might be about their
vetting that might be about reopening
investigations there's all sorts of
actions we might take but the first
thing is to systematically review that
that's a massive piece of work to do
that to do that thoroughly
the second piece of review and redress
work that we're we're doing is around a
refreshed look at betting
so members might sort of remember from
different conversations you've had but
whilst the police national computer has
criminal records criminal convictions on
it
um and we're confident we know all the
officers who have criminal convictions
um and people shouldn't be too troubled
necessarily about that in itself because
if someone's got a caution as a 13 year
old position of cannabis that's not
going to rule them out being a police
officer so so there's lots of good
reasons why people have been there as
well as bad reasons but more importantly
the police National Database pnd
has a much wider intelligence set of
risks and other incidents that go beyond
convictions
so we've washed the data technical
people understand what this means better
than I do we've lost all of our data of
our Personnel data so all of our people
office and staff against the pnd
to look at other officers or staff
who've had contact with the police that
may be troubling that we don't know
about
now you do that wash and you get a big
pile of potential positives which will
include positives and false positives
and then that creates a big manual
process to sift through those hits and
that's what we're working on at the
moment and that so that's so that that's
that refresh vetting approach you'll
have heard talked about I just wanted to
explain a bit more detail there and
that's the tactic that um we're the
first people to do it at scale and
that's the tactic that the
um Home Secretary is now asked that all
forces do that do that tactic as well
um
I was on Monday I was with I spent a day
with Professional Standards teams across
two or three buildings across London and
the sort of
the positive thing in all this the sort
of all the people in there they're
absolute they're just ordinary police
officers who happen to have moved into
those roles
um some recently some long time ago
their passion and commitment to take
this on was really
um really uplifting
the last thing I want to say was about
accelerating
um trying to find faster ways to deal
with this Louise Casey commented on the
speed of our cases and we're trying to
improve that
we are unduly restricted by the nature
of our regulations and that concerns me
and it's great that the secretary prime
minister have commissioned a rapid
review of some of the rules about
dismissals and unsatisfactured
performance but despite regardless of
that we're trying to find other levers
ourselves where we can stretch the
existing use of the law a bit further
and push the push the boundaries on that
to go as fast as possible what we're
doing
but if I step back just to finish off
um
you will see progress from us step by
step as we Chase more trust less crime
and high standards which I'm focusing on
here
um we must improve dramatically for
London
but
lifting the stone
and revealing painful truths
will not be resolved overnight
and I mustn't pretend it will do and I
hope you you understand that that can't
be done
we have to prepare for more painful
stories as we confront the issues that
we face
um we've we've discussed before sort of
the systemic failings that create these
problems of these offices of corrupt our
integrity and as we put in more resource
more assertive tactics
as we're more open to people reporting
incidents to us from within and from
without the organization as we more
determined to take on these cases
it will tackle the problems that we face
but it won't it won't be rapid and it
will be painful and in that context
um we need your support and the support
of people of London
um please don't lose heart this week
confront these issues as we do this
necessary and painful work to can
finally confront those and rid the
organization of those who corrupt our
integrity
thank you chair
thank you sir Mark
um in in relation in relation to that
I'm pleased to hear the vetting uh is
being looked at would it would it be
better if it was a vetting service for
that all of the um police commands in in
the in England
I I think at the moment because police
technology and data is
fragmented I I think doing it centrally
would be hard so there's some national
databases with some local databases we
check
um I think it would be hard to create a
national service particularly at this
difficult time okay uh later in the
meeting we're going to be talking about
trust and confidence but it it concerns
me greatly and it must do that things
are going to come out more and more Yeah
the more you look at and we look at
today's
ghastly reporting on PC who's saying
shehab
um who admits full counts of sexual
activity with a girl aged 13 to 15 and
then we find out that he had a role as a
safer schools officer do you want to
comment on that particular case no it's
a it's another ghastly case isn't it yes
um from what we've seen so far he's it
it does look like he's he's vetting had
been done the sexual contact offenses
took place before he joined the police
but
um sadly there were no own and then
whilst he was in the police he was
taking part in what you might sort of
broadly describe as as grooming activity
it is it is ghastly and it's really it's
going to be really obviously you've got
to apologize to the the victims they
shouldn't be facing that at the hands of
a police officer and their families
um but also it's another one of these
cases which will trouble the people of
London and I say I'm sorry for that and
we're going to keep going back to cases
like this as we as we surface them yes
and of course we're all sorry for that
because not only are these cases ghastly
but what it must be doing to the rest of
your Workforce who most are absolutely
full of integrity and must feel it far
more than even we do which is
they both want this sorted out and
they're massively frustrated that most
the conversation about the Met is about
this side of it rather than the amazing
work most of them are doing day in and
day out yes and of course I never got to
a question to the mayor but we see just
how many of our very brave peace police
officers are actually injured at work
and they take all that on board I mean
those figures are astonishing do you
feel that you're empowered to lead the
change that the um that is needed to
turn them around are you being assisted
by
politicians and everybody else do you
feel do you feel supported I I do at the
moment
I'll watch this space
um politics moves quickly doesn't it but
I do feel very supported at the moment I
I found the
um
uh the mayor consistently in the in the
home secretaries I've worked with very
supportive
um they're troubled by the challenges
faced by policing and they're Keen that
we progress and turn things around as
quickly as possible and uh the things
that we've asked for
um have our largely being supported like
the
um for example the review
um of some of the regulations that we've
asked for been in the home office or
um the mayor making sort of full use of
these sort of powers to sort of help us
with our budget this year
okay and you you commented to us at late
last year that there were a hundred or
so officers that you wouldn't dare put
near the public
is there any way you'll be able to deal
with that so that's one of the things in
accelerate we're looking at different
ways that we can
interpret the regulations and see if we
can make more progress on that certainly
the review work that the home office
will do should give us new routes to
deal with them but um I'm looking at
whether we can use more inventive legal
measures okay well let's hope you can
um just to digress very slightly before
we go back into this
we've obviously a lot has come out about
probation in the last couple of days for
obvious reasons and then I read today
that one person is killed every six days
by criminals on probation which I must
say I didn't know clearly this is for
the whole country not not just London
which is absolutely shocking do the
problems that probation obviously
probation have got problems does that
increase workload for the police
is a awful case and I think the
direction operation and the minister
have apologized for
um the clear mistakes that come out in
um come out in that case we try to work
really um really hard with probation
um they are
they do recognize their role in
protecting the people of London
um
but clearly they've got issues they need
to be able to account for that I can't
speak to okay fair enough
um going back to David Carrick if I can
ask Diana lutchford please at what point
was Mopac made aware of the allegations
against David Carrick said we were sorry
um we were first aware we were informed
of his arrest in October 2021
okay and what what is mogpec doing to
support them at in ensuring that that
officers like this
um don't enter them at or what
assistance are you giving them at
um well
um
there's a kind of a history to this in
the sense that uh clearly over the years
we have been talking to the Met about
um
strengthening misconduct
systems and for example are mopac's
evidence and insight have produced two
research reports including one in 2016
identifying the issue of
disproportionality and misconduct which
was which has been published and was
actually noted during uh noted as part
of Louie's case's interim report so
we've been doing research on these
issues
um clearly we don't get involved in
individual misconduct cases because
those are an operational matter
but we have also been talking to them at
over time about supervisory ratios
because obviously it's very difficult
for more senior officers to identify
negative behaviors or whatever else may
be going on the more
officers that they are responsible for
supervising so those those are some of
the kind of strategic issues that we've
been discussing with them
we're also after the cousin sentencing
it was of course the mayor who um called
for Louise Casey's uh review to be set
up he he sought for that to be
commissioned after the cousin sentencing
so uh he was you know playing he asked
them to establish the independent review
and that followed our very serious
concerns about sort of culture within
the Met which the cousins case
demonstrated
um and also of course we are supporting
the Met around uh the reform of police
regulations
uh so where the legislative framework is
inhibiting their efforts to root out
corrupt officers we're working with them
uh to to help distill that the fourth
come the home office review which I
think has actually now clicked off okay
well I'm glad to hear that you're
helping uh the report you mentioned is
five six years old what evidence could
you give us that you picked up that
there were problems uh with the culture
in the map where where where could we
look up that maypak was doing his job
looking at that
um well as I say we have been working
with them on issues like super
supervisory ratios and we have been
talking to them about the culture and we
are now um regularly meeting with
colleagues from the director of
Professional Standards to discuss
learning from cases how that links to
um hmic FRS corruption report
recommendations their wider
transformation plans
um and any emerging themes and patterns
that are coming up okay to something
that Mopac have done that actually
indicates that you were concerned about
that and brought that to the
commissioner's attention before all this
well obviously as I say we don't get
involved in individual misconduct cases
the culture in general
well the culture in general over the
past uh few years we uh as as was
evidenced by uh discussions with the
previous commissioner was a growing area
of concern following a series of
negative incidents which the mayor has
uh described this committee on previous
occasions including
um
the the deaths of Bieber Henry and
Nicole smallman
um okay the Daniel Morgan case so on and
so forth there was a whole Litany of
them which uh reinforced the mayor's
view that an independent review was
needed yes
it was before because I'd never picked
it up from Mopac as being an issue but
I'm very pleased to hear you're
assisting the Met now I'll now go to
assembly member Desai
uh commissioner firstly can I welcome
your determination to um
uh to do you see all what's improved
dramatically
um that's very reassuring I can also
commend you for all the work that you've
done in the last three or four months
um says welcome news uh and what a
particular welcome is that I think
there's been a change of approach in the
Met away from a mode of self-denial to
accepting that there are serious issues
uh to be crippled with commissioner um
you're hoping set will actually really
covered the supplementaries I was going
to ask you but I will still put one
question to you which to some extent you
already answered but I still will put
this to you so regarding David Carrick
how is this violent Predator able to
serve in the police for a number of
years decades even and the pattern of
his behavior go unnoticed and
investigated what was going wrong now I
know any answer because what you are
doing sort of you have answered the my
question to some extent but in 2017
themes Valley police spoke to him in
2019 assaulted a woman drink domestic
incident the matters refer to the Met it
was determined he had no case to answer
English misconduct I mean what was going
in the matter the time a different
commissioner but you were part of this
well a very important part about the
senior management team as well
so I think if we look back at this
there's a combination of poor policy and
poor decisions
um
and sort of what I'm not going to say is
well those policies well that was the
standards and practices of the day I
don't think that's an acceptable answer
if the policies don't make sense I mean
sometimes we can see why things were
different
then but they're different now other
times it doesn't actually make sense I
don't think I don't think that's I don't
think that's a defense but for this
I I fundamentally think the at the core
of this is an issue about
an allegation is made against an officer
it doesn't meet a criminal standard
for prosecution
and many of these were investigated by
other police forces outside London
Thames Valley Hertfordshire et cetera so
this isn't simply a met issue and that's
let's assume those offices and those
forces did the best they could do for
whatever reason there wasn't enough
evidence to prosecute
um
and obviously that's a decision that
involves CPS generally
the question is what notice do you take
of that after that point
and
sometimes on an individual case
when you don't have enough evidence to
prosecute
you're still left with a worrying
intelligence picture
sometimes after an investigation you
think actually we've investigated this
there's little evidence of any concern
about the person it was alleged against
sometimes you see actually no we still
there's enough in this to make us
concerned even though it doesn't reach a
criminal threshold
and too often in the past
that wasn't thought about you said well
no criminal prosecution nothing further
to see here push it to one side and when
carry on as normal so that was the
individual issue
and then there's the system issue that
even if that's the right decision on one
case or two cases you start to get more
cases not looking at the system points
and Louise Casey in her interim review
she's got her final review coming that's
a couple of months her interview which
focused on the misconduct process one of
her points if you recall was I think her
phrase was about joining the dots
actually seeing these patterns of
behavior and certainly
um with this individual
even if individual cases didn't provide
a lot of evidence
to justify dramatic intervention as you
start to the pattern build over the
years it certainly should have done and
it didn't so that so that's what we've
got to fix which is why we're going to
anticoption abuse command part of the
resources there about increased
intelligence looking at our vetting
again because of course the
um the thousands
people who we've
um who we're looking at in
um in projectonics
are across more than a thousand cases so
some of them have got multiple cases as
as you might expect so so that
systematic look has not been done as
wisely so that's the that's the failing
and that's what we've got to fix
and I'm sure underneath it there's
probably some cultural issues it's not
just system apology there's some
cultural issues in terms of people's
judgments
um
but fundamentally those are the those
are the failings that cause and that's
why I think when you look at these sort
of actions I went through and I'm not
going to repeat them all again you can
see how they're picking off the sort of
systemic issues in terms of vetting and
data looking at the picture being more
proactive more resources in that space
it's all about the same issue thank you
thank you thank you assembly member
pigeon thank you very much and thank you
for the detail at the beginning
um which probably answer some questions
we may be planning later on but actually
um shows how much is going on you've
said a thousand people yeah uh have been
pulled out from this big review You've
Done but how many are there outside of
that thousand such as the case we've had
today that you know are going through
the justice system that we might see
coming out in the coming weeks and
months
uh so I mean looking at this of just the
next few weeks ahead
um
uh most most weeks there's two or three
officers going to court for criminal
cases which tends to be a a mix of
sort of
dishonesty
violence and sort of violence against
women and girls type offenses to give
you sexual offenses Etc so there's
probably two or three uh
two or three a week that are sort of
appearing at court it's hard to know
when these cases will come to conclusion
because sometimes they Leap Forward
because something that was a
the court process hearing all of a
sudden someone decides to change and
plead to guilty so exactly when these
casual finalized isn't always clear
um but there's a there's a there's a
trickle of them and we're going to be
surfacing more as I said earlier of
course you are but there's already two
or three a week you're expecting to come
out which is horrific and how long is it
going to take you to get through this
thousand odd cases so
I've said we've trying to moving Heaven
and Earth we've got to do it thoroughly
to have got through it all by the end of
March and I said I'll report publicly at
that point
and what that will say is well I we've
gone through the thousands there were
sort of sort of X that actually we're
happy we're not concerned about
there are why but we're now putting into
vetting reviews there are Zed that we're
now bring into fresh investigation so
sort of be that sort of be that sort of
update we'll be able to get to that's
that's what we're looking to do that's
the initial bit and then there'll be
months obviously and the months of doing
those yes exactly and in terms of your
boosted Professional Standards unit
dealing with this work how many offices
have you got in there and how confident
are you about the quality and integrity
of those officers given we saw come out
recently a constable in that particular
unit is now being investigated over
alleged sexual assault of a female
colleague that worries me that you've
got people in there who may have a
different judgment and may review cases
in the wrong way because perhaps their
own behavior has not always been good
yeah we've worked hard on the vetting of
the people in that unit I was with them
yesterday and I was impressed by other
people
um I met I mean sort of and for example
on the
on the sort of sexual offending side
we've
basically built a you know you you
looked at in the past I think you've had
a recent session with um Commander
Southworth about our public Protection
work more generally we've basically
built a public Protection Team in uh
into Professional Standards so those
officers who are highly skilled at
dealing with victims of
um of rape sexual assault domestic abuse
because of all the nuances that come
with those cases in terms of specialist
evidence Gathering
um uh the particular
importance of victim support and the
particular tactics in doing that in a
way that works for women who are victims
of such crimes so we've actually built a
dedicated so all the officers in that
um it's a large part of them have got
specialist experience in that world led
by a very impressive detective
superintendent so we're trying to get
all the right skills and capabilities in
there to be able to do as good a job as
we can do the total number I can't
remember the total number we come back
to you on that sort of we increased it
by about 30 but I can come back to the
exact numbers helpful that that's good
to her and then as part of this almost
retrospective work you're doing there is
an issue that officers will have left
the police and staff and there may be
reasons for that for behavior of
colleagues and so on um I was reading a
really interesting piece um in one of
the newspapers eye news about an officer
who left within 11 months had come from
the criminal justice service they had a
lot of experience that could really
benefit the police and it was a culture
of dehumanizing language cutting Corners
the sort of words she used or she has
used to describe how they call members
of the public the team she was with now
clearly this is not all police officers
but they're are you going to look at
talking to officers who've left
to find out if there are particular
reasons again to feed into this massive
cultural review that you're doing yeah
so we have we have done we have done um
some of that and we're always interested
in in that feedback and it's very
obvious isn't it that our we are sort of
our attrition so as we look at
recruiting in a tissue and our attrition
is is higher than we would like it to be
um and
it must be possible and it's likely to
be true that some of that is because
some people having a bad experience one
of the things that
struck me when Louise Casey report was
published and we were talking about that
and talking with officers
about how
this is not pervasive because lots of
officers
have very positive experiences and I had
um
I had sort of sort of young black
officers say to me I'm angry about this
report because this isn't true this is a
fantastic organization it's the best
place I've ever worked
but then you have another black officer
doing the same job on a different team
saying it's exactly true and I'm angry
because you haven't dealt with this
which sort of it goes to the point about
this is this is pockets
but it's too many pockets that exist
because systematically we haven't been
good enough and that's that's the and so
it's finding those pockets and one of
the things for the anti-corruption abuse
command to do is to be more proactive
using more sort of
um covert techniques where we're just
going live with our sort of lawful
business monitoring which is about being
able to monitor internal Communications
more um sort of more intrusively where
there's where there's good cause so
using all those tactics where we
identify teams that we are concerned
about okay and exit interviews of course
exactly I'll leave it there Jeff thank
you thank you and of course the fire
brigade are finding exactly the same
there's pockets of issues colleagues
we're going to have to step up the pace
please assembly member Miami thank you
um my question is for smart my first one
has been answered um but I just wanted
to ask you so londoners will note that
um David Carrick is from the same
command as Wayne cousins
and
we've heard in the past you know there
are some bad apples but it's got to the
point where there are so many bad apples
perhaps we need to throw out the whole
barrel and I say that not to kind of say
that that's necessarily what needs to
happen but I wonder where you are along
that Journey if those pockets are just
so intractable how that's being
addressed if there are clear issues in
certain areas
so I think it's really important that no
one interprets me saying there's Pockets
that it's just it's a few bad apples
it's more than that I think I've been
very clear about that and there's a sort
of system system failings and that's the
challenge but being really clear that
the majority of our people are really
good people and they care about policing
London that's the tens of thousands
um but the hundreds have got more
traction and there's more of them
because we haven't been strong enough
and systematically strong enough and so
we are I'm not going to talk about
particular commands generally we are
looking at units functions and working
out where do we have warning signs of
of problematic culture that might be
about how complaints records it might be
about internal reporting it could be a
whole range of different it could be
about
um the demographics of the team and the
movement of people in and out and and
what that looks like
um clearly parliamentary and diplomatic
protection has been
um more than one concerning issue and so
we've been doing a big review of that
um Deputy assistant commissioner
um Helen litchup has been leading that
and that's coming to a conclusion and
looking at
what are the system issues that
affect the culture in that environment
and they're finding some quite
significant issues
it's an unusual
setup protecting a whole load of
premises armed officers having to be on
post particular times and the
the way it's been constructed has
undermined the ability of Supervisors to
supervise just the the setting of hours
and rotors Etc and that's a long
conversation that is is not for now but
fundamentally so we're looking at those
system issues that can set up the
leaders and the team to be successful
together as well as dealing with the
sort of toxic individuals such as the
ones you mentioned thank you that's
really good to hear and reassuring
um really quickly I just wanted to ask
you if you're confident that um the
mat's going to meet the deadline of the
31st of March to identify people from
the wash that you talked about of the
police national computer
um I'm gonna move tell Helen high water
to get there it's there's a lot to get
through but we're determined to try and
do that
thank you assembly member devanish thank
you good morning sir Mark um I wanted to
go back a point you made a little bit
earlier in terms of the morale of your
staff specifically with this drip drip
drip of these poisonous cases two or
three a week you're saying are going to
come through what are you actually doing
to raise or increase or or defend morale
internally and to reassure your officers
and civilian staff there's a better
future a better met going forward please
so generally publicly I try to keep
going back to the point that we have
tens of thousands of great people I'm
posting the bit that gets that's never
the bit that gets reported frankly
um and so for us it frustrates them they
they understand why that is but it's
it's a it's frustrating for good people
who are in a in a profession and care
about
um care about what they do so keep
trying to get the positive stories out
there but there isn't always the
bandwidth for them
um internally
there are
um part one if when we talk about sort
of uh plans going forward and the draft
strategy we've we've published recently
the turnaround plan
um one of the strands in there is about
setting officers up to succeed because
they feel there are various issues about
how their duties are managed about their
equipment about technology the whole
range of issues like that which could be
better so trying to make sure that their
working environments and the tools and
equipment and support they feel around
them
um is as good as it can be because they
don't feel it is at the moment I think
that's that's a fair judgment and we're
going to try and tackle that and in
terms of specific numbers if you've got
any retention figures because clearly
we're in a wonderful jobs Market in
London at the moment and they can all go
and get a better job elsewhere in terms
of money so in terms of retention
numbers you've got anything you can
publish to show that number hasn't gone
down dipped during this crisis over the
last year or so and if it has how it's
going to go back up in terms of
retention please so uh we can sort of
write and do course with some detailed
numbers but the
over the last year our
aspiration to grow our police numbers in
line with sort of national and local
investment is getting more and more
difficult
um we are going to be high hundreds
behind our Target for the end of March I
think we've said some of that public
before if I say it again so and that is
a that is a combination of
sort of it's both the Recruitment and
the retention so the retention issues
are
um steadily creeping up in terms of the
numbers
um leaving and recruiting I think we've
recruited somewhere around nine and a
half thousand the last three years so I
think there's a there's an element of
there's probably only so many people who
want to be police officers and you sort
of start to sort of exhaust the market
there's certainly the paid
competitiveness I'm very I'm very
concerned about police officer pay
um and some of the stories I hear and
some of the research that has been
published recently about that so I think
sort of clearly the operating
environment and the sort of and the and
the public debate will affect those
issues as well
and so we are looking hard at
what can we do to try and improve that
but it's it's very difficult and there's
a the next pay round of reviews is
really important for police officers I
think
thank you of course says the extra pcso
is coming in which is very welcome to go
through the exactly the same vetting as
police officers I'd have to double check
that it's very similar it's certainly
very similar I think there's a little
bit more that police officers have but
it's it's very similar Chief at some
point that we could be told that that'd
be grateful assembly member Russell
uh yes I just wanted to pick up on the
uh safer schools officer issue that has
come out today
um you said that the sexual misconduct
events has happened before that officer
joined the police and then the grooming
activity happened while he was working
in the police as a safer schools officer
So that obviously has
um huge implications in terms of vetting
and safeguarding and also makes one
wonder whether are you are you thinking
about what the role of safer schools
officers is you know what are police
officers doing in schools are they being
used in a constructive way to divert
young people from the criminal justice
system or is it actually introducing
risk into our schools we've had child q
that you know this isn't the first case
of a problem happening within the second
of a school so do you have any advice
for head teachers who have safer schools
officers in their schools so I I sort of
this is obviously a concerning Cason as
a local BCU command teams are speaking
sort of are communicating with um with
head teachers and and we'll update them
we have
we do do extra vetting for schools
officers
um
the issues in this case is
sadly none of the offenses that he
committed before joined the police had
been reported until more recently so
there was no way we could have known
about that
um
so it it looks like the vetting
procedures were
sort of sensible
but sadly he was clearly an
inappropriate person we now know to be
in a school and we've got a bit more
work to do to double check whether I
think we could have spotted done to spot
that in terms of the role going forward
um
as part of you've heard me talk about
the strongest ever neighborhood policing
and sort of schools officers are a part
of police and communities working
together to deal with issues
um the vast majority of people I see in
a sort of in education welcome that sort
of positive relationship and work as you
say to divert people from crime spotting
problems early and helping divert young
people out of crime has to be has to be
an ambition particularly when we see
issues like county lines and and those
areas where young people
um perhaps at a difficult moment in
their
um in their growing up get drawn into
those issues and spotting that early
between teachers and police and trying
to find ways to deal with it I think is
really important so that that's the
mission we've clearly got a tragic case
here um but that shouldn't deter us from
the positive work that schools officers
work doing working with teachers and
others to reduce crime the I mean it is
it emphasizes the importance of
safeguarding because the first it sounds
like if the other issues hadn't been
reported before he went through the
vetting process then the grooming in the
school was the first activity and and so
it's you know what I suppose the thing
to take away is what can you learn from
that to protect other people in other
schools and be interesting to see how
that works thank you
I think it also shows that people if
there is a crime committed must report
it as soon as they possibly can because
it
as in this case then at least you'd have
been alerted to it before the gentleman
was put into schools okay assembly
member Garrett
morning two quick issues that have come
up if I may somehow firstly this
question of you mentioned two to three
offices per week is the sort of par rate
of officers going through the court I
just wondered what what is the
historical trend of that look like and
what does the future in your hopes and
dreams look like is that just a kind of
Baseline level of people who you would
just expect to see because it feels to
me like quite a high number even for an
organization of 35
000 odd people
um it's a it's a higher number that I
wanted to be in the long term but it
sort of we're going to see a lot
happening over the forthcoming months
and I mean it said all of these X so for
example all these extra reports coming
in at the moment from our Appeals some
of those
some of those will turn this criminal
investigations
um
if one of those reported today becomes a
criminal investigation
if it's a guilty plea probably won't be
until sometime in
2024 and if it's a trial it might not be
till 2025 just to give you a sense of
sort of particularly with the current
Log Jam in the in the criminal justice
system in London so so that's a a sense
of the timeline that we're going to face
we have historic records in terms of I
think dismissals Etc the sort of
the number appearing at court I think is
it it's not something we have reliable
data on frankly what I see is what I can
see coming up in the next few weeks of
course some of those cases appear
multiple times I think well they might
plead guilty today or they might go to
trial so that that name in this week's
two or three is the same name in the two
or three in a month's time and three
months time as well so that's it's just
the ongoing business okay fair enough
the other the other question that came
up was about
um uh retention and also about assaults
on police officers which is you know
unfortunately part of the line of work
of a police officer so one of the so my
question is how well are officers
Frontline officers supported if they're
assaulted in their work how are they
supported not just in terms of immediate
first aid but in terms of the sense of
this is an organization that is looking
after me and that is going after the
person and taking seriously the fact
that a person has assaulted me in the
line of my work is that something that
the Met's always been good at is it
something that you're working to improve
so we have a there's a protocol there's
a national protocol that we follow so um
Hampshire police developed this and so
in the met we call this op Hampshire
because everything has to have an
operational name doesn't it which is
something that something something that
Diana says but sort of there's a set of
protocols about the follow-on with
officers
um I'm going to keep so there's the
welfare side of it another key part of
it is actually treating them as a victim
um one of the issues in the past was
sort of it was not treating an officer
as a victim in the same way you would a
member of the public
um so you you only gone through a
traumatic incident write your own
statement it sort of used to be it isn't
that anymore so it's sort of it's being
sort of more
um sympathetic in that way but it starts
right at the sort of right at the scene
um we had an incident
um a week ago where an officer was
um badly assaulted making an arrest in
his his heart stopped and his life was
saved by his colleagues with a um with a
defibrillator and that's the second time
that's happened in my four months as
commissioner that we have an officer
who's alive
um because colleagues because colleagues
literally save their life with immediate
first aid
um and that sort of really sort of
upsets and troubles me that that happens
that frequently but the support from
colleagues is fantastic
I think made me ask the question it was
a story that I was reading this morning
and outside the met but it was an
officer who was assaulted a person who
assaulted him was only given a caution
part of the caution was to write a
letter of apology to the officer so
firstly the officer was annoyed that the
the level of sanction was just a caution
and secondly the sanction within the
caution of writing the letter of apology
never even happened the force didn't
seem to this officer's mind very keen on
making it happen and eventually he left
the force because he thought this is not
a place that values my time or my
injuries is that is that the sort of
thing that a met officer might face
I would hope not frankly I would hope
not I I wanted to take these issues
seriously
um I think there are
um at least sentencing guidelines and
sort of expectations in terms of
sentencing for this area but I
I
do think it could be taken more
seriously these thoughts on police
officers I think it is a big issue and I
think it
it should be seen like sort of on a
contempt of course or something it's
actually sort of fundamentally
obstructing and impeding Justice in a
very
completely unacceptable way and it
should be seen as something which in
a large portion of cases people get
custodial sentences okay thanks thanks
Jeff thank you and I agree with that
protect the protectors is something I've
always absolutely supported
um unfortunately with all these things
coming out it sort of muddies the water
somewhat and that's not fair to all
those exceptionally good officers out
there absolutely who we will thank every
single day for what they do putting
themselves in so much danger and
nevertheless we must get through this
very difficult time our next section is
on trust and confidence which of course
is all all ties into what we've just
been talking about colleagues we are
running very late as you will know if
your question has been covered please
don't ask it again
so first of all we're going to go to
assembly member Ahmed thank you very
much chair good morning panel Ms ludford
what specific work is Mopac doing to
support the met in rebuilding trust and
confidence including action to reduce
disproportionalities in levels of trust
between different groups of londoners
so we've taken significant action to
help address the issue of of trust and
confidence and of course that is why
terrible incidents like Carrick are such
great concern because they further
damage the trust and confidence of
londoners which which means you know
it's an on this is an ongoing issue for
us I mean for example we've overseen a
whole scale overhaul of the Mets gangs
Matrix due to the annual reviews which
Mopac conducted which has resulted in
more than 1200 people who are deemed low
risk being taken off the Matrix and in
fact the database is now at its lowest
number since 20 2012 which we hope will
uh increase trust and confidence one of
the really significant things was of
course the mayor's action plan to
improve trust and confidence uh
particularly among black communities and
I'm sure that uh Kelly can give more
more detail about that but that was
particularly about the disproportionate
use of police powers on on black
londoners
um as a result of the road traffic stops
Pilot within the action plan uh which
saw the Met recording vehicle stops to
make sure that they are identifying any
disproportionality relating to ethnicity
that has actually are now been picked up
in the National police race action plan
uh they've they've taken our lead and
they're developing a new code of
practice to to drive change in that area
uh We've also been scrutinizing the uh
Matt the Mets use of strip searching for
some time indeed prior to the
publication of the child Q report
um through the Mopac oversight oversight
board which is something that we uh
committed to as part of the action plan
and we're beginning to see some results
from that very very important work for
example in the last quarter the um the
debt the Met conducted 16 more thorough
intimate part searches on children which
represents a 64 reduction on last year
which is really really positive and
we're also doing work to progress
tackling disproportionality and youth
Justice and and many other things I
don't know if there's anything you'd
wish to add particularly on the action
plan Kenny
um so sorry forgive me Mr Bowie we're
running out of time thank you love that
was quite thorough thank you
um commissioner
um but before I ask my question I'd just
like to pay tribute to the officers that
save not only their colleagues lives
every day but members of the public so
um in my constituency as you know just
before Christmas there was the awful
incidence of the incident of the O2
Academy in Brixton and I would publicly
like to reiterate again and pay tribute
to the officers who saved members of The
public's lives that night and I don't
think that's spoken about enough so
thank you to those officers I was lucky
enough just a few days ago to do a night
shift from Peckham police station on a
Friday night with with the with a team
and I cannot I really cannot impress how
in how impressed I was with the
professionalism we had a suicide attempt
we had a stabbing and just watching how
the office has dealt with that like a
machine you know they went in like a
machine it was an amazing thing to do
and it was and watching the offices in
action was amazing
going back to my questions
commissioner what are the immediate
priorities for the turnaround board how
will these be delivered who sits on it
and how many times has it met
thank you so we've been creating a
turnaround plan which we published last
week so
I'm sort of I'm determined that we get
on with things in a hurry because
there's a lot to do and
so we've developed a plan and I'm Keen
to get feedback on it so rather than
hesitating we need to get on and do some
things and so having
um done some sort of initial pushes on
certain themes in the first three months
wanted to do that that plan takes
account of hmic reports various other
reviews like Morgan and some of the
other things that Donald has mentioned
it takes account of our performance
issues takes around the fact we're in
the engage process takes account of the
Casey report and so we've tried to put
all that together and it really does
three things
it says so under the headline of so
we're going to deliver more trustless
crime high standards it's like how we're
going to measure and assess that and
drive performance improvements
how we're going to deal with improving
the way our values
um build a healthy organization that
everyone succeeds in
and what are the what the priorities for
change what are the most important
things we have to tackle to improve what
we do for London and those are the those
nine priorities for for change as part
of doing that
I was Keen that we sort of look outside
for others ideas and comments and so the
turnaround board is helping us as a
challenge panel and sort of to to help
criticize Challenge and improve the
quality of that plan so
um we've got um Community
Representatives we've got
um hmic are there we've got a local
Authority Chief exec
um obviously Mopac are there so except
so and we it's met
three or four times since I started and
it's going to keep meeting as that
external challenge so that our planning
isn't just in a on our own
um the other thing it's doing so we've
also got the chair of the College of
policing Chief counsel Andy Marsh the
other thing we're looking for is to
bring in best practice from elsewhere
so so the College of police will say
well actually if you're trying to fix
this issue
force x is really good at that or and
hmic can help as well so it's about
getting outside in help and getting
different opinions as we try and focus
on where we're going and of course this
plan is only a working draft we're going
to crack on with it but over the next
three months before we get to the first
of April we'll have Louise Casey's next
report there'll be other things and
we'll get feedback from perhaps
yourselves and others and that will lead
to sort of refinement of it thank you
very much commissioner could you tell us
a little bit about the leadership
academy and what you are hoping this
will deliver and what progress has been
made in establishing it
we don't invest enough in our leaders
that's a an absolute challenge for us
almost the vast vast majority of
leadership training that officers get
is entirely operational so learning to
be a Firearms Commander or a senior
detective which is about those those
technical skills are of course important
but in terms of leading and managing
teams of Staff setting standards
thinking about how you connect to London
and how you place a city as as as
complex as London we don't put very much
investment in that an interesting
comparison if you look at our chief
superintendents who are running big
units with maybe 1500 officers
um if you compare those to to kernels in
the middle in in the Army
um an army colonel since leaving
Sandhurst will have had 72 weeks of
leadership development
our two superintendents if they've had a
handful they're lucky
um that is an extraordinary difference
so now I'm not going to be doing 72
weeks of it sort of that's not that's
that's sort of if only
um but my stake in the ground up I want
every leader in the Met to be getting a
week's leadership development each year
that's the stake in the ground that I
put and that's what the academy is going
to try and deliver so we're going to
sort of try and repurpose some of Hendon
he's probably the right answer to this
and we want to work with the College of
policing we want to work with perhaps a
London sort of um like business school
type institution
um and we want to work with London's
communities and some of the groups in
terms of how we how we do that and the
team at the moment are focusing on
developing a package for Sergeants for
the next couple of years okay thank you
very much thank you chair thank you and
on the back of what assembly but Ahmed
said I would urge anybody that
scrutinizes a place or throws stones at
them comments on them to actually go out
on some of these police shifts from
literally walking the beat so I've been
out with the firearm officers Etc their
professionalism is astounding and
perhaps it would make people think twice
before they just freely throw thank you
very much as it were assembly member
devonish well said yeah
but
well said chair and uh short answers
please uh some up to these questions
because we're behind time what are the
key learning points from The Innovation
hubs the Met held across London and how
will the Met take this forward to
improve trust and confidence please
so those have been focused on different
crime reduction initiatives in local
areas getting different groups together
I don't have a sort of hit list of one
top four or five things but perhaps I
can write back to you afterwards that'll
be great
um you have said that the Met will a
quote will build the strongest ever
neighborhood police in model the city
has ever seen end quote what does this
actually look like when will londoners
expect to see real change and can I just
add one further point of 500 pcsos that
have been announced by the mayor a
couple of weeks ago how will that
demonstrate uh change in addition to
what we're discussing
uh so we have
there's multiple issues to be dealt with
here at the core of this I want policing
that is I've described it as Community
crime fighting precise Community crime
fighting so police and communities
tackling crime together that's how we
succeed best policing shouldn't be
imposed it should be done should be done
jointly and we haven't always got that
tone rise
the neighbor policing resources are the
Cornerstone of that approach but they're
not the whole of it
so just starting there our neighbor
putting resources are lower than they
were a decade ago for a whole range of
obvious reasons that you'll understand
um I want to rebuild that the number of
police officers there on paper is
comparable to what it was a decade ago
but the abstraction levels are
um are too high and that's something
you've discussed here before so so
getting that more reliable is important
pcso wise we're about 1600 fewer than we
were a decade ago in neighborhoods and
um Keen to improve and it's great to
have the money to start that sort of
start that scale and we're looking at
the role of PCA the role of pcsos and
police officers in neighborhoods the
work they do how they have the most
impact on crime how to improve
engagement we're looking at new
technologies to get a better more
granular understanding of different
communities concerns
in alongside that we're going to be
looking at how the rest of the Met
connects into community policing and
connects into neighborhoods to support
their activity
thank you um I'm told we've recruited
now 16
753 of the promised uh 20
000 uh government promise uh can you
provide an update on when you expect to
meet the targeted recruiting an
additional the figures four five five
seven officers here in London and what
discussion have you had with the home
office about that please so I think
those numbers you're using there are the
National numbers
um I would love to be recruiting 20 000
more officers
indeed so if you've got a checkbook for
that then I'd be very very very grateful
um so our share of it I say we're we've
recruited nine and a half thousand
officers in the last
um three years I think the time span is
we're struggling to get to the Finish
Line in terms of getting quite as high
as we need to as I said earlier with the
conversation about Recruitment and
Retention
um and I think we might fall sort of uh
sort of high hundreds short of our
Target at the end of the year and we're
working hard on what levers we can pull
to try to try and get catch that back up
but it is a difficult environment all
the reasons earlier pay meets reputation
Etc and could you write to me on the
point that we discussed earlier as well
about retention as much as well as
recruitment that'll be really in more
detail be really useful to the committee
okay thank you sir Mark okay the problem
is recruitment isn't it it's not because
there isn't the money there yeah
absolutely fine thank you assembly
members sahota
thank you chair now good morning
commissioner good morning and let me
Echo the comments I've met by my
colleagues of the Gratitude of Rio to
the airport please for the hard work you
do and particularly for Western Borough
commander who keeps me well informed
with issues in my part of the world
right
um you've appointed Professor Lawrence
Sherman as he Met's first Chief
scientific officer can you please
clarify the remit of the role and the
initial focus of the work of his work
yeah so I'm very I'm determined that we
are
intelligence-led and evidence-based so
the evidence of best practice
um uh Larry Sherman brings with him a
he's a globally renowned criminologist
he's last laterally sort of professor at
Cambridge criminology Department
um what we're looking to do is to bring
all that best practice to London and get
more rigorous in terms of our working
out what works and some of this is about
how you apply data science you'll have
heard me talk previously about sort of
using data science to get better
identifying um London's most dangerous
predatory offenders because we've got
tens of thousands of sort of men in
London who in the in over the last few
years have got convictions or
intelligence about domestic abuse child
abuse rape sexual assault Etc actually
be able to prioritize that requires sort
of data and an analytical approach that
leans on criminological evidence so it's
that sort of thing is what we're looking
to do likewise we're going to use the
same evidence-based approach to thinking
about how do we
how do we allocate the 500 pcsos how do
you sort of do that to best effect if
you want to deliver more trust and less
crime where's the best place to put them
so Professor chairman will also be
looking not only at the
data collection but also what data is
irrelevant because there's a difference
between data and then for useful
information absolutely absolutely so so
he's got a background in all sorts of
research using
um data to inform policing and say
widely cited on sort of global best
practice but across things like we've
discussed or stop and search practice
how do you do stop and search
differently that increases trust how do
you bring ideas like procedural Justice
to
um to stop and search so there's a range
of things that we're looking at and
we're having he's been in post lights
two or three months and we just
finalizing the sort of work program that
we're working to
thank you thank you chair it's
fascinating we'll be watching that thank
you assembly mother pigeon you're just
picking up on the data point
um obviously we touched on earlier about
the issues with probation the prison
service this all 4K Zara Alina
um that's been in the news again this
week
you developed these tools within the Met
what will you be doing or will you be
doing anything with probation the prison
service for them to be able to use these
tools because you're putting this
investment in that can help keep
londoners safe I'm very very keen to do
that there is increasing evidence that
um
data analysis can massively improve upon
human only risk assessment uh you still
want
we don't want a Minority Report
environment if anyone's seen that film
where this is also all done by computers
that's not the intention but when you've
got big volumes of data and complex
environments technology can help people
make better decisions and there's
there's evidence into risk assessment
that that can be very effective good I
hope you're able to share that tool and
can I just go back to talk about the
leadership academy all that is really
good to hear but are you doing a review
of Hendon and and how fit for purpose it
is in terms of the new policing Way
Forward that you want to develop because
you know a lot of us they offer X
officers there the staff there may be
very good they may be old school though
and you may want to be refreshing that
so are you looking to review Hendon so
um I mean hendon's a a site more than a
more than an academy at the moment but
so we are looking at recruit training
certainly at the moment as I say there
isn't enough leadership training and and
that's why we're doing this um doing
this investment
it's not
it's not just our thinking so we've got
the College of policing involved we're
looking to work with Business Schools we
want to work with Community groups so
this is this is not going to be a meta
only designed I see these very much as a
partnership and so Hendon will be kind
of refreshed in all its trades exactly
yeah lovely thank you thank you chair
thank you we're now moving on to
reducing crime which of course hopefully
will
I did so I wanted to come in oh beg your
pardon we're not moving on but we'll be
quick though won't we as soon
um
I'm sure you'll have seen the reporting
of the Mets multiple failures in the
Salam Muhammad case
including making no effort to contact
the Keller and ignoring discovery of a
burglary bag outside of her house in a
deliberate attempt to avoid paperwork
commissioner can you reassure this
committee and londoners that his
failures won't happen again and the lute
issue of violence against women and
girls seriously
I I need to write back to you on that
case
okay
one big events coming under section
three
but anyway no no so one final question
commissioner commissioner so trust and
confidence which is what this section is
all about this is about people's own
personal experiences cultural issues but
also perceptions so it's in that context
that asks you this question I wrote to
you yesterday regarding the party get
inquiry and asking you to reopen it I
know you will respond in due course but
I do want to point out that also Phil
that this is a key issue for trust and
confidence in that the police should
operate with a fear and favor and the
public need to know that criminality is
probably investigated wherever it takes
place that you will go where the
evidence takes you that is not one law
as many people said most people said I
would say for the rich and powerful and
another law for others wouldn't you
agree
no
um the the so you do accept that should
be wonderful conditions about there was
about five questions there yeah and I'm
not and I'm not agreeing with all of
them
um the
the met before I returned put a lot of
resources into doing a big thorough
inquiry which has now concluded
um I've got a lot of very important
things to do for londoners and it would
take something startling to cause me to
reopen that which I think is unlikely
okay thank you well let's see what the
common privileges committee comes up
with okay meanwhile back in London uh
well we are in London yes
okay thank you very much for that
interjection we're now moving on to
reducing crime which of course will help
with trust and confidence is being
started by my colleague assembly member
Russell
thank you chair and um just briefly just
going back to the um piece about
Professor Lawrence Sherman
um it was good to hear you say you don't
want a Minority Report situation will
you be publishing information so
londoners understand what data is being
used in policing and uh and and what uh
and how it is being used in this more
data-driven policing environment
and any big strides we make to do things
very differently we'll be very
transparent about them okay thank you
very much
um so
um moving on to the reducing crime um
piece
um you've talked about the more trust
less crime higher standards
um and I'm just just briefly but broadly
can you say what concerns you most about
current crime Trends in London and
relating that to your turnaround plan
what part of the turnaround plan is
going to be the most challenging to
deliver
I'm I'm
not sure I'm
I'm not sure I'm particularly concerned
about one part of it possibly the
um
culture and Leadership side is
particularly challenging but actually I
think the challenge is the scale of the
overall plan and sequencing it and
managing those those things alongside
them at each other I think when you look
at when you if you read it and think
about the the work to do under each of
those nine change priorities if you add
all that together
that's not something that you can rush
through in a year and tick off all those
there's lots of planning a lot of
sequencing
um there's difficult issues around
technology there's all sorts of issues
around people and training and
development and and so choreographing
the whole thing is the bigger challenge
frankly
and
the area of the turnaround plan so the
item three we're going to prove we will
provide a compassionate and effective
service to victims and other members of
the public and one of the ways you're
going to deliver that is to ensure
attendance at every home burglary yes
and that it gets reported
um so how have you achieved the 80
attendance at residential burglaries in
just a few months
um and how have officers made time for
that and has anything been
de-prioritized to make space for it
and we haven't explicitly de-prioritized
and that's the the challenge in this
they're not it's not a massive number of
incidents so it's it is manageable
within the the workload
the the 80 number is slightly
um misleading because
I think we're probably attending pretty
much all the burglaries
of people's homes
the challenge is a few years ago the
classification was widened so
a crime is classified as a burglary
dwelling
even if someone just goes into your shed
and steals a pair of shears so it's not
actually in your home so the the the
classification for the home office
currenting rules is very wide
um my promise is about Burgers of
people's home because that's the
intrusive bit discovering when you go
out in Spring sometime in the past six
months something's gone out your shed is
not the same as someone invading your
home is it so
that 80 percent of
burglary dwelling classification I I'm
pretty confident includes pretty much
all
invasions of people's homes and we're
trying to Quality assure the data in a
different way to be certain of that
thank you thank you chair
thank you assembly member Prince
thank you chair
good morning commissioner good morning
good morning
um
can you confirm the scope and purpose of
operation tenacity please yes thank you
so tenacity was a is a operation to show
how we can be more focused uh going
after the most dangerous offenders and
so
um we did that over three months before
Christmas
and we arrested
2530 dangerous offenders
um we were looking at issues such as
wanted offenders absconders from Court
various lists that we have and they're
saying can we reduce the numbers that
are outstanding if we're if we're more
focused on that and so those 2 530
included 153 rape suspects 106 for
robbery 174 burglars
etc etc
um and so it's it was very positive it's
that
data-led approach
that will help us bring Crime down
further by being precise going out so
who are the most dangerous people how do
we use our limited resources to best
effect for London and do you have a
figure on how many rests have been made
as a result so so it was a 2530 leading
up to Christmas oh that was the actual
number of arrests yeah sorry to miss
heard you okay thank you and um
so what progress do you think you've
made in your first 100 days to tackle
serious and organized crime and what do
you feel are the next steps so
the first my first hundred days was
really just about testing some new
tactics as we started to build the
turnaround plan I think two
two things I would highlight on the on
the success on organized crime firstly
our work tackling
um drug Supply in London
folk which is more about reducing
violence
so work that started about 18 months two
years ago on county lines and we've
stepped up the resources in that work
and and if you like started doing work
on what you might call city lines so the
the line selling drugs within London
rather than those selling them further
afield
uh we're increasing the number of
arrests we're making we get about I
think nine well over 90 guilty pleas on
those cases because of the methodology
we're using um using phone data and
other things to convict people
um what we're finding of the sort of
tens of people a week we're arresting
for drug Supply who are running these
lines these are men of violence
one in ten of them have previously been
arrested for murder
one in six of them have been previously
arrested for firearms offenses one in
three have been previously arrested for
Grievous bodily harm well over 80 have
got previous convictions for some sort
of weapons or violence offenses and so
by going after the men at violence
behind the drugs lines you're having an
effect on on on violence in London and
um of course some of the spin-offs of
those operations are safeguarding cases
where you've got some of the young
teenagers who've been coerced and
pressured into delivering the drugs on
their behalf I think that's partly
behind our success over the last year in
terms of
reducing murder where murder was down
about I think 16 or 17 last year a half
the number of teenage suicides in 2022
compared to 2021 I think a big part of
the success in that has been this drive
on this activity the second highlight I
would be where we're experimenting with
new methodologies to deal with the sort
of plague of online fraud and uh work
we've spoken about before with operation
elaborate where
um we arrested a couple hundred people
using a sort of an online fraud selling
website frankly Ford methodology selling
and that's a massive operation we've
conducted I think 60 or 70 000 victims
who we think of being victims of those
offenders
thank you that's very very promising
um so they're from person uh sanction
detection rates are about point seven
percent they're from motor vehicle is
about point four percent according to
figures I'm giving here and taking a
motor vehicle 0.9
um what uh is a met doing to catch more
of these criminals
or to improve the sanction detection
rate uh so we are trying to catch more
criminals I think if if I step back and
so if we have a conversation about crime
performance on serious violence we're
doing well uh detection rates on rape
and sexual assault are are going up they
still need to be higher but they're sort
of in the better half of the of the
country
um we're doing well in terms of reducing
um a whole range of different crime
types our problem at the moment is is
robbery and um and um and theft from the
person
um sort of Street Robert said from the
person those are the two that are
um ticking up most concerningly
um I think they're still behind where
they were pre
um
uh in some ways being pre-locked down
but they are they are concerning so
we're doing a lot of operations on that
um sort of patrols hot spots arrests Etc
but it's something we've got to make
more progress on
and I think if you're honesty on that
um so in your first 100 days and since
the murder of Sarah everard what
improvements have you made on the safety
of women and girls in London
so if if we look at our we're putting
more of our
um
police resources into the public
protection environment and we're trying
to strengthen that area because the case
load there is overstretched
um there's been a whole range of
initiatives working with women across
London to identify vulnerable locations
we've done proactive patrols we've made
very powerful arrests there was a very
impressive arrest by a couple of
officers just a couple of weeks ago who
um identified a poetry male who was
um
literally out there with equipment to um
to attack a woman with
um so we're making a lot of progress on
those cases our detection rates I
mentioned earlier have gone up so we are
doing a lot in that space But there is
so much more to do
thank you
um when violent and prolific offenders
let's say such as Jordan McSweeney
um are released from prison are the Met
made aware of this and what plans do
they put in place to monitor them
so it depends on the level of risk but
the most serious risk of offenders are
the The Joint activity between police
and probation
um they're often joint boards in terms
of joint risk assessment boards and
coming up with plans in terms of what
police will do and what they will do
that's how the system works at the
highest end of risk but there are
um there's a there's a great volume
which the police will get told of
routinely I think pretty much all prison
releases but many of them are low risk
individuals and there's
um perhaps some some follow-up from
probation service if someone's
unlicensed but many of those cases the
police don't have an active role in
do they have any power to say ask the
probation uh
service to maybe monitor the person in
the way of say a an ankle monitor or
something so in the highest risk cases
the conditions that are put on suddenly
being released from prison is discussed
between police and probation and so the
more you get towards the most dangerous
offenders in terms of Arts against women
and girls or
ex-murderers terrorists Etc then the
more there's a case conference approach
and a lot of thinking about what are the
best measures and controls you can put
around somebody and the more you get
towards lower risk offenses then
um then there's less of that goes on for
all all sorts of obvious reasons
thank you so following the murder of um
Zara Alina by Jordan McSweeney and the
fact that it took six days for the
probation service to ask the Met to
arrest him what conversations have you
had to improve the speed at which
probation communicates uh with them I
think that's more a question for
probation than it is for me but surely
um the Met should be expressing their
concerns about that and someone should
be having a conversation with probation
about the fact they need to sharpen
their act would you not agree
commissioner I think for others to hold
probation to account and we will do
everything we can to work with them but
I so it's not for me to hold them to
account can I come in on that just to
say what what Mopac is doing
um because I mean clearly this is a
devastating murder
um and uh we have been looking at the
best way to to learn the lessons from it
uh I mean
although there were failings by the
probation service
um at the time of the perpetrators
release
there had actually been a long line of
Engagement with the state uh on the part
of the perpetrator which kind of
culminated in this terrible event
um so um the deputy mayor who chairs the
London criminal justice board is going
to write to Partners across the criminal
justice system this week to ensure that
we're using this tragic event to learn
between agencies about what actually
happened
and also it is Our intention to write to
central government both a home office
and Ministry of Justice to call for for
an independent multi-agency review to
look at how all the agencies not just
probation and prisons involved in this
case might have might have done things
differently so it's clearly absolutely
vital that we do learn the lessons from
this this devastating event
thank you and um
what do you think can be done to
encourage women to come forward on
crimes such as rape and sexual assault
well I mean I think that links to what
we were talking about earlier in terms
of driving up trust and confidence
because obviously these cases do huge
damage to women's willingness to to come
forward to report cases so um you know
tackling the culture in the Met driving
out misogyny uh creating a clearly
anti-misogynist organization is is
absolutely key to that as well as a a
number of measures that obviously the
mayor has been taking to uh to to tackle
women and violence against women and
girls which is a clear area of priority
for both him and the deputy mayor
I don't think I so I agree with what
Donna says but I don't think this is
just about the police I think it's about
the whole criminal justice system and
the support around it
um I mean I think sort of
it it must be probably the most ghastly
and intrusive sort of crimes that we're
talking about here
and to expect a victim to have that
hanging over them the prospect of giving
evidence for two three four years as
we're seeing with some of the cases at
the moment is is completely
unconscionable and I think there's a
there's a we need a much more dramatic
change in the way the criminal justice
system works overall and the police have
our role in that but I I I I I it can't
be just about us
right no no I'm not suggesting it is I
think I think every
um everybody needs to take
responsibility for this and all parties
have a part to play
um just quickly touching on sanction
detection for rape I'll be interested to
know
um what the Met's doing to improve that
but also uh do you know what sort of
success rate is when it does actually go
to court because currently we're only
looking at sanctioned detections of
around six percent I'd have to write you
on the on the court issue so projects
hysteria which Mopac started which is uh
looking at a different approach to
um rape investigation pulling best
practice across the country being much
more offender Centric that's been a big
part of us improving our detection rates
so say we're in the top half of the
country I can't pull them at the back of
my mind at the moment but it's
um detection rates across the country
across rape and particularly fell about
2018 they went down dramatically for a
range of reasons in terms of changing
the law and practice which is a real
concern and then slowly building back up
but they've got a long way to go but I'm
pleased that we're making progress but
we're not complacent about it there's an
awful lot to do
two more questions one really for Mopac
um a scheme in 2021 was announced
allowing people uh
from a domestic abuse victims to stay in
their homes while the perpetrators found
on alternative accommodation how
successful has this been and what more
can be done to find safe places for
women fleeing domestic abuse
um are you talking about the uh the the
new Duty upon us to provide uh secure
accommodation for for domestic abuse
victims is that is that what what you're
for the scheme you're referring to well
I'm really asking you about what you're
doing to uh enable victims of abuse to
stay in their homes and then you
obviously have to find alternative
accommodation for the perpetrators
uh that's something that was announced
in 2021 uh and then also I'm also asking
you about finding safe spaces for women
fully and domestic abuse so whatever you
know yes well we've we've we've made uh
considerable uh investment in Support
Services
um
uh in in in including specialized
response to to support all victims to
have equal access to Justice and and
services
um I mean the mayor's absolutely clear
that women shouldn't be having to change
their behavior and as I say has uh
launched a new strategy that Champions a
public health approach to ending
violence against women and girls uh
which includes um our uh one million
pounds on our education toolkit which
has been launched in schools which is uh
directed at particularly at boys to help
them recognize and Tackle sexist and
misogynistic behavior
and extending the pioneering GPS tagging
pilot program
um to to tag knife crime and domestic
abuse offenders who are released from
prison uh which is which has recently
been extended and in terms of uh refuges
I can I can write to you about what
we're doing there and what our
investment levels are but I know it's
something that we prioritize yeah I mean
if you could on both of those aspects
because it's two very different aspects
is one trying to enable the victim to
stay in their home which wouldn't mean
you have to provide alternative
accommodation for the perpetrator but
there's also what we do to accommodate
those who are actually fleeing domestic
abuse which again would mean housing
that particular victim so it's two very
different aspects perhaps I can write to
you so you can see thank you and finally
uh
the commission if I can ask you this
question what improvements have been
made for whistleblowing internet against
officers showing dangerous and toxic
behaviors
so we spoke earlier about our external
reporting line we've done the same
internally and that's simply producing
sort of
um several cases uh
um several cases a week so that's that's
positive I
I think the most important thing here is
whether officers believe leaders are up
for confronting the issues
it concerns me when I see some
commentators suggest that
people don't report because they're in
fear of their colleagues and Counting
culture type things I don't think that's
the main issue
um I think the main issue is confidence
in leaders to tackle it because if
you're if you were going to report
something against a colleague
you would think I'm gonna put my hand up
and sort of take this take to do this
difficult thing I need confidence the
system will back me and follow through
so I think it's it's more about leaders
and that's the important thing so I
think what we're seeing is with our
commitment what what sort of me and
other leaders are saying
um with the Louise Casey Report with our
response to that we are seeing increased
confidence to report and we're trying to
make sure we harness that by doing a
good job in terms of following through
for example like those alleging sort of
um sexual misconduct and criminal
allegations putting real specialists in
that world so that's the way we're doing
it
thank you
thank you we're now going to move on to
anti-corruption uh question some of
these I think might have been answered
but uh starting off with my colleague
assembly member pigeon thank you very
much
um so Mark you set out very clearly at
the start your action review refresh and
that gave us a great context but let me
just tease out
um a few issues one you said you're
going to come back to us with details of
the Staffing in that unit and also if
you're not at um you know full capacity
there when do you expect to be so that
would be really helpful for us but can
you explain to us kind of the workload
of that command how many current cases
do they have how many so it's about a
thousand I think from this I'm going to
call it a database tool that you
described at the start
um and what is the caseload that that
team are dealing with please
so if we wanted a detailed layout of
caseload I have to come back in terms of
that detail well so the types of work so
you've got
um across the whole of Professional
Standards which you just want the the
anti-corruption abuse command
um I think the anti-corruption abuse
commands particularly your because
you're focusing on reaching out exactly
exactly so support
So within that you've got an
intelligence function so any any sort of
initial allegations how do you need to
research those particularly if you get a
phone call to a hotline so you're
researching the the background of
officers and whether this looks like
this incredibility in it there are some
investigative teams
um there are the key thing on this side
is the proactive work so proactively
going after officers so we've got some
information that sort of Officer X may
be
um
and I just pick something simple like
stealing money from the property store
um how we're gonna sort of how we're
going to find the office how we're going
to get evidence against that officer um
so it might involve surveillance it
might involve others of the research
um likewise we have a unit there that
looks at the the offices we've got known
concerns about we're putting
restrictions on and how we can manage
them at the organization so there's a
range of proactive functions that we've
strengthened I mean we grew it by 30 as
we sort of with existing resources as we
stood at this separate command and um
with some of them recruited some of the
room posts have been recruited and we've
got about a 40 increase in the amount of
proactive and covert investigations
they're doing so the biggest challenge
is capacity
um so we've we've made a sort of sort of
a stab actually this extra capacity will
give us a a good head start on what we
need to do over the next few months as
we get through this review work and the
workload settles down we'll have to
review that capacity and see whether
it's right or whether we need more or
not and in terms of the hotlines you've
talked about you've got the external one
yeah um and and you've talked about
effectively an internal one since you've
been in post how many calls and you know
your absolute publicity around I want to
root these offices out encouraging
people to come forward how many calls
have both of those different hotlines
received so each of the internal and
external producing sort of tens tens per
week each okay low tens low tenses low
tens per week so that is increasing
their workload will you be reviewing the
number of officers in this command
exactly if needed so you can you call
this and at the moment there's quite a
bit of resource pressure there that
we're looking at because you've got both
the increased new investigation workload
coming in
and also you've got this backward
looking pieces of work reviewing the
thousand dollar 1071 old cases if you
like and doing this data wash betting
review so if you overlay more new cases
with reviewing old work it creates quite
a bit of pressure even with the extra
resources so we're constantly looking at
that and also in there you've got the
existing case slope because there must
have been as we know because some of
them are going through the courts the
two or three a week currency must be
hundreds of existing cases that are
ongoing yeah so will you be able to if
you can't give us it today write to us
with that detail that would be great and
that command is taking over cases that
were already in the system presumably
yeah so so we've we've broken out of
what was the Professional Standards
Department we've broken out the
proactive and intelligence function to
cover separate
um a separate command because we think
it
if you want to tackle a problem
you have to go after it you can't just
wait for reports to come in so creating
that stronger proactive emphasis is what
the extra command does but you still got
the the sort of core bulk of of what was
what ezam was DPS in terms of all the
reactive investigations some of which
are internal some of which are some of
the public complaints and officer was
um rude to them or whatever else it
might be okay okay that's that's helpful
and how are you working with the iopc on
on all of this
um the command you know have they got a
close working relationships and we um
the Deputy Commissioner I are very keen
we take a more sort of
um authorized approach to referrals so
we're doing a lot more there's some
mandatory referrals to the irpc but
we're very keen they have as much
visibility as they can cope with in
terms of our work frankly so we're doing
more voluntary referrals to it so to
give them sight of what we're doing and
give them the opportunity to pick up
anything independently if they feel they
need to lovely and finally from me you
talked about leadership and the leaders
have got to be up for confronting the
issues there was an article in the mail
on Sunday from Lord Brian Paddock where
he set out his experience albeit 20
years ago in the Met of different
systems sitting on panels officers being
disciplined officers being dismissed and
then more senior officers reinstating
them despite the red flags now that says
to me that there could still be issues
in leadership roles so what are you
doing around that and secondly will one
of your you or one of your senior team
or even Louise Casey speak to Brian
Paddock because there must be learning
from his experience that could feed into
the work you're doing yeah one of us can
definitely pick up the phone to
um to Brian so
I think some of the leadership issues is
about yeah so
most of our leaders are good people
some of this is about confidence and
skills which is why I've spoken about
leadership and training so it's about
policies that sort of our policies
perhaps
this
leaders feel uncomfortable using them
and so they find it difficult so there's
a there's a lot of work to do to create
a leadership that is
skilled and confident at dealing with
this but it shouldn't all be seen as
this is leaders who don't want to it's
about equipping them and giving the
giving them the ability to do so and
just just find the question that I've
asked many many times I used to be on
the mpa is
there is an issue I probably I would
suggest more in the past around
Freemasons and declaring that and
whether that has any influence are you
looking at all at that to see if that
has any impact or has had any impact in
in this whole process around trying to
root out corrupt officers and people
sometimes turning a blind eye
um it's not something that's come up at
all in any of our intelligence and
research I think um
a long time ago policing put in place a
policy that you had to declare it so I
and I I they don't have to it was never
enforced is that right I'll double check
that um but um I it's not something I've
seen any evidence is a problem I think
we've got
um
many other places to look rather than
that okay that's helpful thank you
thank you very briefly the iopc was
brought up are they getting any quicker
because for a very long time that you'd
have officers not able to drive because
they were being investigated for
something relatively minor and they were
off various sorts of Duties so
they need to get quicker and we need to
get quicker so if you look at the Louise
Casey report I think our investigations
have an average length of a year
their investigations I think was three
or four months longer than that so
um
and given their take on particularly
complex cases quite often that's not
that surprisingly it's longer but both
of us need to be quicker because it's
but if we've got something wrong it's
bad for the victim of that that it takes
her long and if we've got something
right it's bad for the officer they've
got it hanging over that period of time
and so yeah for both reasons this needs
to be quicker absolutely and they're of
course our duty when we lead them
actually doing that exactly okay thank
you assembly lender Ahmed thank you
chair
commissioner you have touched on the
issue of the amount of time that it
takes to look at misconduct cases but I
wonder if we can go just a bit deeper
into that what actions have you taken to
reduce the time it takes to investigate
misconduct cases what impact are your
actions having and what are the next
steps
so
the timelines are coming down slowly the
uh the extra resources that putting
Professional Standards some of that has
gone into that the the big volume is in
this reactive case load and it has been
too slow it's been something I think
mopac's been raising for quite a long
quite a long time so we are seeing those
numbers starting to come down we're
going to have to keep an eye on our
resources levels and as as the previous
member was suggesting in terms of has he
got more work coming in have we got the
resources right to be able to get
through the cases properly but we are
seeing progress on that thank you it is
something that londoners I think very
very concerned about because they don't
understand why it takes so long so it is
reassuring to know that that work is
being done thank you
thank you assembly member Miami
thank you chair and my question is to
Diana and I wondered if you could
briefly outline how Mopac has
strengthened its oversight of met
disciplinary processes in the last six
months in addition to the two points
that you raised before about your work
to date
yes certainly
um I mean the first thing I'd like to
acknowledge is that we do recognize that
this is an area where we do need to
strengthen our our response because of
obviously the increased attention being
given given to these issues the
increasing number of cases the the
particular emphasis that the Met is now
placing on it and shortly we will have
the outcomes of the KC review and of
Dame Angelina's reviews also so uh in
Practical terms we have uh we are
recruiting two additional officers to
the um Mopac oversight and
professionalism team to kind of increase
capacity there
um we also in the last few months uh
well not not in the last few months but
uh over the past
um year or so we've been regularly
meeting with Barbara gray who is the AC
in uh DPS in the met to discuss the
learning from from cases uh how that
links to
um hmic report recommendations and why
their wider transformation plans we also
meet monthly with the met to discuss
high profile cases and identify any
emerging themes in those cases such of
such a sexual assault or use of social
media for example
um we our focus is really on the
opportunities for the Met to intervene
at an earlier stage and to make sure
that they're using data as far as
possible to identify appropriate risk
factors in order to kind of help root
out poor behavior and Corruption and as
as Sir Mark has remarked we've also been
encouraging them to the Met to push the
boundaries of the conduct and complaints
legislation so that we so that
investigations can be sped up and we can
exit offices as quickly as possible
uh I mean clearly you know as we've
we've we've been discussing there are
going to be challenges here because the
action that the the proactive way that
that Sir Mark is responding to this this
issue is obviously generating more cases
uh you know 30 to 40 a week coming
through the helpline that's a positive
that you know those are being surfaced
uh and as he said some of those actually
relate a third of those I think relate
to other forces uh but that's going to
kind of increase the throughput so it's
absolutely key that we are being as
efficient and responsive as we can and
that we've got
um uh effective uh you know resources in
place I'm also conscious that um you
have written to us uh on the your police
conducts uh and complaints report and
that we um owe you a response on that
and that will be forthcoming very
shortly that included um a
recommendation around uh uplift in iopc
funding so we have we have written uh
We've included that uh in a letter that
was sent to home office Minister last
week following the police settlement as
something that we would support
so Mark I don't know if you had any
thoughts on that if um
you how you have found that um oversight
and how it's changed in response to your
approach and since you've become
commissioner and um then to both of you
if you feel like there are the resources
in the Met to um
top hold those High Professional
Standards that we aspire to
so I think in terms of
um a sort of a new leadership team on my
side settling down and working with
Mopac it's been uh it's it's absolutely
fine and we're finding the right way to
to sort of to work together because
there's things we need there's things we
need support on
um in terms of sort of I know policy and
politics and money and various issues
that we're constantly discussing a look
at and so there's a it's that
uh balance isn't it between working in
Partnership but also
um Mopac is there to scrutinize us as
well and so it's getting the mix of
those things right is is is never simple
but I'm very satisfied with how it's
coming
just to add that I'm also satisfied with
how it's going
um and I think it is fair to say that we
have observed
markedly less defensiveness more open
sea and open C more transparency and and
openness uh with with the new uh senior
leadership team and uh we're working in
collaboration with them whilst also of
course maintaining appropriate oversight
okay thank you so we're now moving to is
Manchester's inspectorate uh putting us
as or putting the map I should say into
engage my colleague assembly Mumba
Garrett is going to lead the questioning
morning yeah so we're going to start
with you uh Sir Mark
um so the result of being in the engage
process
um what is the Met uh doing differently
and what tangible results might we see
already as a result of that process yeah
um thank you so the
the strategy that we've published the
draft strategy is heavily influenced by
the engage by the engage process
the publicized letter that started the
engage process last summer
um I think had 13 or 14 bullet points in
it listing an area sort of a to M or n
listing a range of concerns
um and we're working through those some
of those are symptoms of some deep lying
issues that we're we're looking to
looking to tackle
um
exit from engage will come that their
criteria are
um you are making progress and you have
a credible plan to go forward those are
the those are the two things and that's
a a reasonable generic statement so some
of the things that we've done so far
sort of like that have referenced in it
that Daniel Morgan
um recommendations
um uh we're on track to deliver uh most
of those at the moment of about 80 of
those
um the others
the others and some a common theme a big
area is is around victim care and
particularly around contact center and
call handling and that's a big theme in
a in our plan and we're looking for what
we're putting more resources into there
and we're trying to sort of change the
way we we work there there's quite a lot
of fundamental change required in that
in regarding that environment
um in terms of areas like um uh the
Project's nasty we mentioned earlier was
about getting on top of some of our
violent Defender areas another area they
highlighted was um we had a massive
backlog in terms of
um online sexual abuse child image and
sexual abuse referrals and we've taken
that backlog down from thousands to very
few so we've sort of caught up with that
so there's there's several areas which
have been long-standing issues which
we've got got progress on of course
there's more to do and so I think for me
the balance some of the symptoms you can
work through quite quickly some of the
underlying issues let's say like I know
control room not working as well as it
needs to in terms of call handling
that's a big system volume issue which
takes a bit longer to get through but
that's a sort of spread across the sort
of things we're doing okay
um the Improvement plan that HMI asks
you to produce as part of that process I
think you've read to it just now is that
something that you is that public Have
you shared that with the committee
um we've done update reports with um
hmic I mean our Improvement plan is
really we're not creating different
documents we have a strategy that's what
we've published that's what that that's
how we're approaching it and that's that
contains all the things we need to do
I'm really I think one of the things
that's
not helped the met in the past is having
too many strategies with too many pages
in sort of and actually trying to trying
to be really focused these are the most
important things that we need to do to
do for London what they expect that's
critical and that's what that turnaround
plan is is trying to do so we're going
to keep coming back to one document as
much as we can do rather than having so
many different strategies that you can't
see the wood for the trees but that's
the trees you're chopping down to create
to write the strategies on yeah I mean I
mean we we do have email these days so I
mean I take that as a no but I take the
argument for your no that if we just
look at your overall strategy yeah are
you saying that if we look at that that
should Encompass all these various
strands of work you're doing including
this Improvement plan and everything yes
exactly so we look at that study that
closely that should tell us all we need
to know exactly in terms of the um the
engage meetings that happen as little
regularly as part of that process who is
attending those meetings who's who's
sort of in the room so those are chaired
by so Andy cook who's the chief uh Chief
HMI and he chairs them the London HMI
Matt piles in the room
um and then there's a sort of on their
side of the table so to speak there's a
a few other people supporting them and
then on outside of the table so to speak
is is myself and and the mayor and the
deputy mayor again
um uh supported by one or two other
people from sort of from my team and and
Dinah
did you see you were there in the I
assume myself yeah okay okay and um
what's the what are the measures I think
you perhaps suggested this before so the
measures of progress that the HMI are
looking for it's are you making progress
on the things that they've identified
and is there a credible plan so so what
they're trying to say is that the test
to come out to being gay you shouldn't
be Perfection on the basis that no big
organization is ever going to be perfect
but sort of the test should be you
you're in a you're in engaged because
you've got a collection of issues that
are either collectively or individually
so acute that you need special attention
so are you making are you making
progress on those issues
and is the trajectory in the plan
convincing about where where you're
heading to that's that's what they want
to look for okay and sort of thinking
you know the layers further down within
the met the sort of uh that you know not
necessarily the top team who are working
with you closely on it but
um the sort of senior leaders and and
the team further down in the mat
um what's the response at that level to
the engage process
[Music]
um
I well I suppose what I mean is what
does it mean for them or what do they
think it means for them so I think it's
I don't think most of them should be
troubled by it and but by what I mean is
there a
it's for senior leaders to make sense of
the environment that we're operating in
because the engaged issue there's Morgan
recommendations there's Casey
recommendations Etc
it's not for I know a superintendent
who's in charge of volume crime
investigation on a
on a BC you shouldn't be worrying about
all that it's up to us to create a
strategy that captures all those things
and makes it clear for him or her their
role in this is these are the priorities
for them in terms of that context so so
they will see it filtering through an
example of this would be
um the um call handling environment if
we look at victim care if we look at all
the reports we did a big analysis of I
think a thousand recommendations I think
at least we're in it from hmic and other
bodies over the last few years
and what I found was these have been
dealt with us on separate checklists
um which is a very messy bureaucratic
way of doing it
you bring them all together and arrange
them you discover that I think it was
like 22 or 23 of them were around victim
care scattered across multiple reviews
if you bring that together then you work
out what are the big chunks of activity
you need to do to improve that one part
of which is the sort of the initial
contact if you like from the control
room and so you have a systematic
approach to improving the control room
rather than doing trying to tick off
individual recommendations from this
report here and this report there and
that report there if that if that makes
sense so that so what the leaders
uh are seeing is a much clearer uh
simpler strategy as this approach lands
rather than having multiple people
holding to account on checklists which
doesn't get you anywhere no that makes a
lot of sense I think one of the life
experiences of let's call the middle
management in any organization is you
have multiple different processes
ongoing further up in the organization
which each spit out different sets of
priorities exactly several of which are
in conflict and no one tells you how
you're meant to resolve it exactly so
the resolution is happening at the
senior level where as you say there's
this one strategy everything feeds into
that strategy that senior leaders are
creating that strategy and further down
the organization that should mean a
consistent set of priorities and
messages yes and that's why we're doing
an executive redesign in terms of
restructuring our senior leadership and
accountability structures and
performance Frameworks all of that is
it's all sort of for a public viewer
this is all really boring and
interesting stuff I know but it's the
foundations of how you run a big
organization successfully yeah I mean
organizations are a big teams of people
that get complicated things done that
one person can't do by themselves
exactly how that gets done is actually
anyway for me quite interesting how I
end up sitting here
so turning to Mopac if I may uh Diana so
what are you satisfied from opec's point
of view about the the progress that the
matter making and the way that they're
engaging with that engage process yes
absolutely
um and uh as Mark has mentioned the
mayor has been to the people which is
the Curious acronym for the hmrc meeting
that uh that runs the engage process on
a couple of occasions uh to to support
the mayor
um and indeed you know we welcome the
the the scrutiny that that's being
provided
um and and we're keen to use the engage
process uh and to kind of Drive the
fundamental changes that that we that we
need so
um yes the the the mayor is is is
strongly in support of uh the Mets plan
and is participating actively in the in
the process I am Kenny is the expert on
engage so I am going to ask him whether
he wants to add anything
no I mean well I would say there's much
there I think safe to say we're very
pleased with how it's being done we're
very pleased with the level of
Engagement that the commissioner and his
team gave us in terms of the opportunity
for the mayor Deputy Mayor and Mopac to
feed into the turnaround plan it did
feel like a genuine as a partnership
approach there which was very positive
and we are very supportive of everything
so Marcus said in terms of having one
plan which brings everything together
rather than things going off in multiple
directions so not much Dad so what's the
task list for Mopac in terms of
supporting the Met to get where they
need to get to
that's fine
so that's
I'm sorry darling can we ask you to
answer your
CEO that well well our task list is to
look at the various uh aspects of the
turnaround plan there are there are nine
priorities uh within that
um and to scrutinize their progression
um across those of those identified
areas including through our regular
oversight board meetings we we we which
we have every couple of months
one of the questions that I think has
come up here before I think with the
deputy mayor of the previous meeting was
about how it to what extent it reflects
on on Mopac that obviously the Met got
to this position and I was a bit
concerned there was a comment by Sir Tom
Windsor that the decision to move the
Met into the engage process was partly
about losing confidence in the met and
partly about losing confidence in
mopac's ability to turn around the mat
and so you know his view was that it's
not just because the MPS was failing
it's also because Mopac was failing so
what sort of internal Reflections has
Mopac having on on that either on that
observation or on you know in the
problems that that points to yeah I mean
I think we talked about this last time
when Mopac board came before
um the the the committee and we
acknowledged that the hmic report that
has resulted in the engage process
identified some issues that Mopac had
already identified itself
um and yet we continue to use our
oversight function to ensure that that
those issues are being tackled but of
course we keep that under review uh
constantly and uh you know we as I say
we have taken steps to strengthen our
oversight in areas where we think that
has been uh you know has perhaps been
deficient with misconduct uh being being
and Professional Standards deficient is
perhaps putting it a bit strongly but
where it could be strengthened with uh
our oversight of misconduct and
Professional Standards being one of
those of course I mean there is always
learning to take there are so many
different agencies in this space who are
commenting on what the police are doing
uh all of the time so there is always
more that that Mopac should be doing and
that we need to take account of okay
it's just that
I remember getting slightly crossed with
the deputy mayor at the time when she
gave a very similar answer and you know
the language of the answer you've just
given me was about continue to and keep
under review that's not the language of
an organization that's having a sort of
deep and meaningful conversation with
itself about the how it's inadequacies
led to the problem you know it's it's
very different from the language that we
now hear from the Met about how there
are problems we acknowledge the problem
that we met acknowledge the problems and
this is what we're doing about it the
language of continue to and keep under
review and of course you know any
organization dot dot that does sound a
bit like I mean I'm trying to find of a
diplomatic alternative for complacent
but I've struggled so I'm just going to
say it does come across a bit like that
I would I would challenge complacency
sorry
let me let me phrase the question
differently so what are the real actions
that have taken what are the changes
that have happened in Mopac as a result
of this where you said we've got these
problems this is what we're doing about
it differently
so
no Diana you're the chief executive yes
well we we have made various uh
structural changes
um as I say increasing resource in
specific areas
um so there are there are there are
things that that we have done and we
continue to keep Mopac under review and
uh in ensure that we are doing the the
best the best job that we can I would
you know I I would certainly challenge
complacency did you want to be meant to
be blunt the best way you could
challenge my charge of complacency would
be to list things rather than well let
me send you a list of things in fact I
think that may be one of the outstanding
areas on the on the on the yeah in in
your follow-up from from the previous
session okay I I said unconscious of
time and but and also that you know I've
asked you the question a couple of times
and you haven't listed anything I think
if I were cheap let me just say I think
if I were chief executive and
organization that had a deeply
meaningful conversation with itself
about the problems it has and how it's
got into difficulty and somebody asked
me what are the things that you're doing
in this organization that you're leading
I feel like I'd have at least one or two
on the top of my head otherwise I would
wonder you know
what am I doing can I just come in if
it's good so first of all no no I'm
sorry the questions are directed okay I
will I will I will I will send you a
list okay if I can note my
disappointment but I think that's the
end of it yes okay before we go
it is please we've got the chief
executive here tell me Diana these
meetings with the HMI do you attend all
of them no they're quite um they're
quite Limited in terms of numbers so uh
when you know there will only usually
allow us to admit three to two or two or
three people so how do you the chief
with respect you've got some art Rowley
there you can't get more senior than
that and the mayor who I have to admit
you can't get more senior than that
um you're the chief executive officer we
hardly ever see you I would have thought
that is such a high level meeting and so
important to get right Mopac should be
doing everything they can to assist them
at to if they see anything that's wrong
to assist them we must all assist them
at for our own sakes
so you don't go to any you send your
staff to these meetings as opposed to
seeing what's happening yourself is that
is that correct well I think I talked to
you when I was last here about my
distributive Leadership Model which
means that I am here to lead Mopac not
to be Mopac you know and there are other
people that that can undertake
responsibilities I don't have to do
everything personally it may be uh it
may be sensible for me to go to a future
Peapod meeting and I I will decide that
as and when but clearly you know I I
task and I I think about I I think about
capacity and what other
um responsibilities I may have on a
particular day and whether it you know
it would actually add much weight for me
to attend as well as Sophie the mayor
Mark and and Kenny yeah it's very
important and I will just say thank
goodness so Mark is leading from the
front uh now if we can move over please
to assembly member sahota to finish this
section
thank you chair
um commissioner when do you hope to come
out of the engage process
that's
not really fell for it then that's um
that's not in my gift I
we're trying to work up the exact
criteria under those headlines I gave
early with hmrc and that might give me a
view I mean I'd like to get out next
month that's not going to happen um that
that said slightly globally as soon as
as soon as it's possible we have a lot
to do I'm not in any doubt on that and
I'd
I think if I obsess about a process
that's slightly dangerous for London I
should be more focused on what we're
doing for London for a whole range of
reasons including the fact that hmrc
have made some very legitimate
criticisms and we need to tackle them
that you have the capacity and the
capabilities to deliver the changes that
the
hmrc frso are looking for I think
um
sort of a headline yes but there's a lot
of building to do
um a sort of in organizational terms the
sort of you look at that you look at the
sort of turnaround plan and look at the
themes underneath it and the work to be
done
that is a lot of organizational
leadership and change and there's
technology in there there's training
there's a lot of work to do sort of
pulling together coordinating delivering
an improvement program of that scale is
not straightforward and
the way the the sort of the Met
as I find it
doesn't have the
um hasn't built the capacity capability
to do that and that's not surprising
because it's a new strategy so getting
that around so building a new leadership
team getting the right support from
inside and from outside in terms of some
of the different programs all of that
change management sort of work
um that's going to take some time to
build but that's what we're doing it's
not there's not a resistance to us doing
it in terms of our budget propositions
it's in there and and Mopac and the
mayor have been supportive
um but it's not gonna you can't switch
that capability overnight
um and and one other thing is um that
the peer report highlighted the the call
time response well the ambulance was
failing on the national targets
um this was a short-term priority for
improvement
um where are we with improving those
times
um we have been improving I can't pull a
number off top of my head I mean and
also if you look at
um uh that then feeds into our response
time so our eye grade our immediate
response to to 999 calls where there's
immediate life at risk or a fender at
the scene
um and our response then to more
standard incidents which are things
within an hour both of those they're
still below where we want them to be but
their percentages are now starting to
slowly creep up which is positive
and and Dana are you happy with the
progress the police are making on those
core times
great okay thank you well well done
colleagues we've come in exactly on time
because uh the chief executive Daniel
lutchford has to leave at 12. you've not
finished there so Mark I'm over eight
um so thank you very much to Diana
lutchford and Kenny Bowie